RAF recruitment has been in the
spotlight for months ever since its boss
resigned group Captain Lizzie nickel
refused to implement what she believed
to be an illegal order to prioritize
women and ethnic minorities over white
men to hit diversity targets
finally the head of the RAF faced
questions on her resignation from MPS
she determined I understand about 160
cases of positive discrimination had
taken place
and she ended up having to resign not
wishing to go through with this policy
so my question today is
did the wrong person resign some of what
you said in your opening remarks implied
that there were different standards
applied that there was active
discrimination against
people who you know
white men
um but that was that was that was not
the case this was people this was people
within the organization who felt that
they were acting within the law that air
Chief Marshals sir Mike wigston did
admit his ambitious goals to improve
diversity had been translated into
unattainable targets for recruitment
officers that put intolerable stress on
them and that was a yeah and that was a
failing of the organization where an
aspirational goal becomes becomes an
individual Target
despite the mistakes the defense
secretary stood
Mike wigston is it has been an
outstanding Air Force officer and I
think he's you know
perfectly entitled to stay to the end of
his uh you know normal deployment
whether that happened could yet depend
on the results of an inquiry into the
resignation that are due to be made
public soon
Deborah Haynes Sky News